-The President held an impromptu
press conference today,
lashing out at Democrats
calling for his impeachment.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
This morning, Democratic leaders
were scheduled to meet
with Trump at the White House
about infrastructure.
Now, why the Democrats
were meeting with him at all
is beyond me.
First of all,
he's never kept his word
on any promise
he's ever made to them,
and, second,
he's fighting Congress
on literally every front
related to their investigation.
In fact, before the meeting,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi,
who's facing increasing calls
from her own caucus
to impeach Trump, accused him
of orchestrating a cover-up.
-We believe
that no one is above the law,
including the president
of the United States.
And we believe that the
president of the United States
is engaged in a cover-up.
-Yeah, he is.
So why are you meeting with him?
That's like responding
to someone's birthday e-vite
by writing, "I resent
the day you were born,"
and then still clicking,
"Will attend."
Now, it will not surprise you
to learn that Trump
did not take kindly
to that remark,
and shortly afterward, he called
an impromptu press conference.
And you knew right off the bat
this was gonna be a weird one,
because before Trump
even got there,
he had a sign printed up
in front of the podium
with the words "No collusion"
and "No obstruction" on it.
First of all,
this is such a dumb sign
because he made
the words "No" super big
and the other words super tiny.
[ Laughter ]
I have a feeling the staff at
D.C. Kinkos voted for Hillary.
[ Laughter ]
If anything, this looks like the
least effective anti-drug PSA.
[ Laughter ]
And sure enough --
sure enough --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump's press conference
was predictably off the rails.
He started out
with an obvious lie
that he just assumed
everyone else would agree with.
-I just saw that Nancy Pelosi
just before our meeting
made a statement that
"We believe that
the president
of the United States
is engaged in a cover-up."
Well, it turns out
I'm the most --
and I think most of you
would agree to this.
I'm the most
transparent president
probably in the history
of this country.
-No, we would not agree.
I mean...
[ Laughter ]
I mean, we could see
right through you, but I don't
think that's what you meant.
He always tries --
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
He does this thing
where he always tries
to trick everybody into thinking
they agree with them.
He's like a guy on a first date
who tries to sneak in something
like, "So, I think you'd agree,
we should go back to my place,"
and you're like, "Uh, you
haven't been reading the signs."
[ Laughter ]
Trump then complained
about the hearings and subpoenas
issued by the chairman of the
House Judiciary Committee,
Jerry Nadler,
who's from New York.
Trump's administration
has repeatedly obstructed
Nadler's investigation
and defied his subpoenas,
and Trump complained
about Nadler
during his press conference.
-Jerry Nadler, who's been
an enemy of mine for many years,
he fought me in New York --
unsuccessfully, by the way.
I've had great success
against Jerry.
-"Great success against Jerry?"
You know you're the bad guy when
you literally sound like Newman.
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump is now
openly defying the law
and refusing
to work with Congress
unless they stop
investigating him.
It's worth remembering
that Republicans spent years
pretending to care
about the Constitution,
and now Trump
is exposing them all as frauds.
In fact, during the campaign,
Trump pretended that he, too,
was concerned
about government overreach
and that all he wanted to do was
get back to the Constitution.
-It's all about
the Constitution of -- of --
And so important,
the Constitution,
the way it was meant to be.
I'm a very strong
Constitutionalist.
I mean,
I feel so strongly about it.
The mainstream media wants
to surrender our Constitution.
I feel very strongly
about our Constitution.
I'm proud of it.
I love it.
And I want
to go through the Constitution.
That's what we want to do.
I mean, we want to bring
the Constitution back.
-What do you mean bring it back?
He talks about the Constitution
like he's rebooting
a classic TV show on Netflix.
We want to bring "Friends" back,
and this time, there's gonna be
a lot more Marcel.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was just echoing years
of empty Republican rhetoric
about respecting
the Constitution,
and this week, we got to see
just how empty and meaningless
all that rhetoric was
when one Republican,
Michigan Congressman
Justin Amash,
became the first member
of his party in Congress
to call for Trump's impeachment.
Amash laid out his reasoning
in an extensive Twitter thread
where he cited
the Mueller report
and the Constitution's
section on impeachment and wrote
"Our Constitution
is brilliant and awesome.
It deserves a government
to match it."
And instead of celebrating him
as a champion
of the Constitution,
his fellow Republicans
slammed him.
Trump even took to Twitter
to call Amash a loser.
And when Amash was asked about
Trump's comments on the street,
his answer was simple
yet effective.
-Sir, what about President Trump
calling you a loser?
-Okay.
-Honestly --
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, yeah.
I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That probably
is the best way to respond.
You know, just treat him
like he's a grandpa
in the nursing home.
"The nurses
are stealing my pills,
and they want
to sell my organs to Mexico."
"Okay."
[ Laughter ]
So, instead of joining Amash
and actually
reading the Constitution,
Republicans are standing with
Trump as he stonewalls Congress
and openly defies the law.
For example, the Trump
administration is refusing
to comply with a subpoena
to release Trump's tax returns.
Now, "The Washington Post"
reported this week
that a confidential draft memo
from the IRS
said the tax returns
must be given to Congress
unless the President
invokes executive privilege.
And yet during a hearing today,
Treasury Secretary Steve Mnuchin
insisted the President was right
not to release them,
and also
that he had nothing to hide.
-Do you think the American
people have a right to know
what's in those tax forms?
-No, I don't.
Presidents are not required to,
and the American public
knew that he didn't release them
before they voted for him.
-Do you know
what the President's hiding?
-Can you repeat that?
I'm sorry.
-Do you know what he's hiding?
He doesn't want anybody
to see them, so...
-I don't think
he's hiding anything.
-Yeah, no, he is.
I mean, when you have something
and you won't let people see it,
that's hiding.
That's what that word means
on our planet.
[ Laughter ]
Also, Trump's
always hiding something.
He spent his entire life
lying about everything
from his net worth
to his businesses
to his personal life.
If we subpoenaed
his driver's license,
we'd probably find out
his real name was something
totally different,
like Tidally D. Wigglesmith III.
[ Laughter ]
I hadn't noticed the picture
the first time.
[ Laughter ]
"Are you good with the picture?"
"No, that looks great."
[ Laughter ]
And not only is Trump
hiding his tax returns,
he's also telling his aides
not to comply with requests
to testify before Congress.
This week, for example,
he ordered
his former White House counsel
Don McGahn
to defy a subpoena and skip
a hearing on the Mueller report,
three weeks after Trump's
Attorney General William Barr
also refused to show up
for a hearing,
which means we've now had
two congressional hearings
in three weeks with members
talking to empty chairs.
And you know things are bad
when C-SPAN is getting attention
for shots of empty chairs,
because C-SPAN specializes
in shots of empty chairs.
Whenever you see a close shot of
a member of Congress like this,
it looks like they're talking to
a bunch of their colleagues
until they take the wide shot...
[ Laughter ]
...and you see
that no one's there.
I mean, look at that.
That looks like
a college lecture hall
during a class
no one wanted to take.
You know, something like Geology
in the age of Social Media.
[ Laughter ]
Democrats want McGahn to testify
because he's a key witness
in the Mueller report
and he has evidence about some
of the most damning accusations
of obstruction of justice
against Trump.
For example, McGahn said Trump
ordered him to fire Mueller
in the middle
of the investigation,
but McGahn refused,
threatening to quit.
And in doing so,
he used some colorful language
that news anchors have been
happy to repeat on air.
McGahn spoke with
the president twice
and understood the directive
the same way both times.
In response to that request,
McGahn decided to quit.
He called a lawyer,
drove to the White House,
packed up his office, prepared
to submit a resignation letter
with his chief of staff,
told Reince Priebus
that the President had asked him
"to do crazy [bleep]"
-Don McGahn
says to Reince Priebus,
which is the third witness
to this incident,
"The President asked me
to do some crazy [bleep]"
-If there's one thing
we can be grateful for
in this otherwise horrible time
it's straight-laced news anchors
just letting loose.
Used to be,
you'd tune in to the news,
and Walter Kronkite
would solemnly read
the day's headlines,
and now journalists
are like drunk Red Sox fans
lighting cars on fire
after the World Series.
"[Bleep] hey, bro,
that's some crazy [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
I mean, pretty soon...
[ Cheers and applause ]
At this rate, pretty soon,
MSNBC is gonna have a show
just called [Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome to "[Bleep]."
It's like when the redacted
Mueller report first came out
and Wolf Blitzer
read Trump's
expletive-filled response
on national television.
-This is what the President
himself said,
and I'm quoting him now.
He calls it "Total [bleep]"
-It's so bizarre to see someone
say those words
in such a dry tone.
It's like
an episode of "Star Trek"
where they give Data
a profanity chip.
"Captain, I've detected
a goddamn anomaly
in the [bleep] warp core,
bitch."
[ Laughter ]
We need to hear from McGahn,
we need to hear
from Robert Mueller,
and we need to hear again
from Barr,
who's basically been threatening
to turn the Justice Department
into a political weapon
to be wielded against
the President's opponents.
Last week,
Barr appointed a prosecutor
to examine the origins
of the Russia probe.
And at a rally on Monday,
Trump responded to chants
of "Lock them up"
by telling the crowd
his Attorney General
would look into it.
-This phony witch hunt that
we all went through together,
it's a disgrace.
If that ever happened
to the other side,
this thing would've been over
two years ago.
And you know,
it would've been treason.
They would've called it treason.
And that's what it is --
it was treason.
-Lock them up! Lock them up!
Lock them up!
-Well, we have a great new
Attorney General
who's gonna give it
a very fair look.
-If an angry mob chants
"Lock them up"
about your political opponents,
the proper response isn't
"We'll give it a look."
That's how a mechanic responds
when you ask them
to check your motor oil.
"We'll give it a look.
It'll cost $2,000."
And then you say,
"$2,000 for motor oil?
That's..."
-Total [bleep]
This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]